better believe that food is going to be
human i assume we're in the
post-apocalyptic world
and i am getting started strike before
they can strike
that's how you survive
i'm arie shafir and i'm back to answer
the internet hold on i forgot how this
works
okay i'm ready for it i'm ready for the
tone because these aren't going to be
legitimate
like solid questions would you rather
suck yeah
one dick for fifty thousand dollars or
get one thousand for
every dick you suck oh
there's a lot more money in the ladder
yeah man there's no cap at 50.
yeah however i don't know i think i'm
gonna take the 50 at once
that's a sucker's move they always try
to get you on with like lotteries i
think they take the 50 at once
because there's a chance i might get
sick of it yeah like
48 you're like i can't do it yeah
there's a chance i might get sick of it
so it's like
yeah there's a chance you don't mind it
that much and i keep doing this forever
200
easy way to drum up business yeah i'd
film it for my only fans
ah think about this yeah have you ever
had any uh are you on the kinsey scale
you're already gay tendencies
no i've had gay friends though does that
count
no no no that doesn't answer the
internet
would you rather walk with a rollerblade
on your left shoe for the rest of your
life
or have an angry [ __ ] walking in front
of you slightly slower than you
then you want to go for the rest of your
life and for the record the
midge has a bad attitude he's not like a
friendly guy uh-huh so you can't even
talk to him yeah he came here like it's
like a certainly prick
i can't bring around the park
that's a special kind of hell i think
the only one would put me in jail
one would put me in jail it's the angry
[ __ ] that would get me out of the hell
i would have actually killed the [ __ ]
i assume i'd probably just say
i have to and then problem solved yeah
then i'm not walking
i get to be a replacement [ __ ] but in
bed in prison
i'm not walking so he would be around i
obviously understand the question
there'd be always no matter what
but i need to be light here strapped
down
would you rather be an extremely good
looking paralyzed person i already am
that
my butt uh qualifies or a hideously
hideous fully functioning person
i mean yeah it's full full functioning
it's it's [ __ ]
pretty great i was with my buddy we were
talking about the world series we're on
break
talking about some bad beats we had
gotten and um
this is gonna get me in trouble internet
but uh but uh we're like
[ __ ] some guy stuck down the river
with the [ __ ] four i can't believe
this
and then some guy who was like those
messed up at the head guys that are like
they all head like
like one-third head two-thirds body he
just like pushed by on the wheelchair
it's like
and they were like [ __ ] bad boots
suck out and then we both like looked at
him we're like
ah you know what life could be
this is worse right at the end of the
world exactly
so i mean fully functioning but i mean
we're talking hideous you're look
oh you're talking you're [ __ ] no i
don't care disgusting no it's okay i can
i can [ __ ]
i can shovel food into my [ __ ] i miss
foreign gullet
i could do something i think you're
crazy if you take the other way who
cares what you look like
would you rather watch your come on guys
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
hundred year old man
or watch your mother kill someone watch
my mother kill someone come on that's
ava
ovio to the max watch your mother kill
someone obviously
oh that wasn't even that you would do
anyway
you know you would have a problem like
looking at your mom like
like i look at her in a different way
the way you discover like the pictures
of her trip to italy from college you're
like wow
you look so cool back then same [ __ ]
you'll be like oh wow
for sure it's different but like not in
a worse way
that's you need to couple that one with
another positive would you rather watch
your mom kill someone
or would you rather yeah we get like 10
you have 50 bucks a week for life but
you have to go down somewhere you'll get
it every week
all right can you still go to your
barber if he's very racist
yeah i mean okay we're gonna go with
that the guy cuts good hair
yes otherwise you'd be like electric
it's like he oh he knows it he's been
doing it right
for sure i think it has no effect on the
hair or on the product there
you could say you'd use it as a time to
[ __ ] talk about it was racism but you
know you're not that person
you know the person that goes along with
anything you just wanted to stop so
you're like yeah it's crazy that's what
you're going to be
it's fine a lot of us are like that uh
he's getting that haircut and you're
getting the [ __ ] out of there
we've all had two talkative barbers you
deal with it
you gotta deal with it no it's you gotta
research it i mean that's one of those
why would you walk away if you get a
hardcore one
you're not gonna get the opportunity
again to like listen
what are they talking about i wanted to
interview that guy fred phelps in my
pocket or skeptic tank i want to get him
so bad
the guy who ran the westboro baptist
church i want to be like hey dude i'm
not even going to attack you but like
what's your plan here like what are you
going for what's your like
how are you going to get there i just
want to hear about it so you go to a
[ __ ]
burial of a non-gay soldier
and you'll be like yeah gay gays are
queer
whatever and you just like disrupt that
but okay so
yeah you have to have a plan it can't
just be craziness what's that plan
i would have loved to have seen that
what led to that
if you could [ __ ] any girl you want for
the rest of your life but you could only
ever watch
women's sports would you do it oh you
get used to it
you get used to it yeah you'd have to at
some point but like
you'd get used to it anything you see on
tv it's like oh yeah like some winter
olympics from whatever and you're like
okay
yeah not even once when are you like pan
ams or something whatever then you're
like okay i'll watch
it's it's dumb yeah so you could do
anything the rest of the world is still
getting to watch
so you know you're missing out yeah
right did you see that like nope i was
watching you know women's curling last
night
but also i'm going [ __ ] any girl for
sure i'm going [ __ ] a girl
would you rather build your own shelter
or hunt for your own food
uh i don't want to build a shelter thing
because that's just work i'm not the
kind of guy i'm upscale i'm managerial
uh i would hunt for my own food because
you better believe that food is going to
be human
i assume we're in a post-apocalyptic
world and i am getting started
strike before they can strike that's how
you
survive yes hunt my own food and
everyone's on the cooking menu how long
would it take
you to eat a human right away first of
all they're going to be enemies get rid
of them that way and then why waste
that's where judaism comes
i mean you are in a [ __ ] foxhole
we're in a bunker together
[ __ ] goes down i'm dead in it no no no i
want you i need support
anyone else we come across yeah yeah you
know anyone clammed up with you
yeah so that all right we have a good
run and we kill this guy we eat him and
kill him
yeah then there's nobody else for a
little while okay listen
obviously if it goes goats go to that
point where we haven't seen anyone in a
while yeah we're gonna turn
we're gonna turn but until then we
couple up we learned a jerky
would you jerk lebron off for all his
athletic ability what ability
a has-been who's ready to retire can't
last the full season
what ability are you even talking about
wait would i jerk them off for
yeah but even now i still yeah
yeah i can also jerk off
i mean either way how would you turn
them off either
him standing here me like pulling him
like
you know by the way not that much higher
but how tall is he six nine
i'm six three all right whatever
like there that you know although i have
to do this because it's gonna get tired
he's also wide though lebron james is a
wide guy he is but that would be the
fastest way to get it done to be honest
yeah
and we both know you would not pull
towards you no no you were not fully
would you rather lose a leg or never be
able to have sex again
ooh damn i love these legs
no i'll lose but never be okay here's
how they trick you
never be able to have sex again with one
leg
you're it's not like you have unlimited
options you don't have the options you
had before
you have some new options but many many
less options and those women
the new options they're wild i was gonna
say the new options
they [ __ ] they [ __ ] don't sew it up
leave it open you'd be the number one
guy
would you rather [ __ ] the hottest girl
celebrity who has a dick or
bit diesel with a [ __ ] wow i think it's
the dick with the celebrity with the
dick
listen here's the deal if i could think
that vin diesel had like a great
clean tight [ __ ] maybe i think he does
i don't think so i think he's got a
blown out no
i think he's got a swallowed a grenade
[ __ ] blown out [ __ ]
multiple levels uh i'm just girl
celebrity i mean
sell the hayek at her prime but she's
not that anymore i don't know but she
but but she would have a
nice ditch she would have a beautiful
day hot girl would have a cute clean
dick
so smooth and like oh
and milky tasting oh my god and her jizz
would come out just
full pineapple oh yeah just oh
it would be an honor to suck your dick
selma i would love to suck your dick
would you rather spend the rest of your
life blind or inside an olive garden
i'm going olive garden but it would not
be a great existence
just because i can hear so quickly does
not mean i wouldn't see the hell of an
africa but i
walk around i move around i invest more
money into the wuhan uh
uh novel coronavirus lab to like if i
gotta be stuck in there
every get something good next time
everybody's gotta be stuck inside
good first attempt if you got ten
thousand dollars a day for every day you
didn't masturbate
how many days could you last all right
that's another hum thing
that's another home thing you're gonna
say after like a day first of all you
might
no you'll last a day but after one day
you're going to start going like
you know what it's going to creep in
your mind like maybe i can do two more
days
and then because you're going to start
wanting to two more days and i'm like
that's 30 grand let's
call it but if you can last until like
date eight or nine
it becomes your new norm yeah you could
just go
and think about what you could do with
that think about how many people you
could pay to masturbate
in front of you oh i don't think i would
do that you because
you have the option ten thousand dollars
a day i'm trying to make i'm trying to
live the most celibate life possible if
i'm watching people masturbate
okay okay no i'm more involved in like
the goodness of the world so i want at
least if i can't do it because i'm the
best masturbator i want more
masturbation in the heart
but you can [ __ ] though right yeah you
can [ __ ] easy easy
loophole and i guess who finds him
steinberg and steinberg taking your
clients right now
we will find loopholes for you if you
were general in the civil war
and you get a t-rex or a modern war tank
to find your side
which of those two are you talking to
you got to assume that t-rex is on your
side
it's a trained t-rex like that he's not
just like going correct oh
damn you get [ __ ] up some [ __ ] the t-rex
i think listen only because i don't
think it's the best in terms of winning
the war but artistically the t-rex is
what you want to be looking at
you're gonna be retired at some point
you win the war like two seconds yeah
but you come over there oh
what a joy what oh you were right
that is not even a hard question yeah
and like what are they gonna do with the
civil war
what the [ __ ] loaded their muskets it's
not gonna have any damage
that'll be my favorite part when he
picks up a guy like
spits him out and that hits somebody
else yes oh yes
if i could go back in time oh don't even
doesn't matter which side are you
fighting for
i would love to see that if you had to
watch your biggest enemy [ __ ] the girl
of your dreams or if you're married
would you do it no absolutely not
get lost you're ruined
my biggest anime yeah like if tom sagara
[ __ ] the girl
no i'm not emmy's with her man no me and
the um the bases from the aos these have
like real beef
who the base guy from the i don't know
i'm just making [ __ ] up
i gotta stick with that [ __ ] and just
kept rumors
going
[Laughter]
i'll figure it out again i had to pull
me i got this once i went on uh
somebody's podcast
and i talked about dante not dan sandra
um
uh sean o'connor john o'connell sean
o'donnelly donnelly
i haven't gone too long sean donnelly's
name came up and he's like yeah the
heart attack and stuff
and they were like what are you talking
about oh yeah he was in the hospital
he's like no
didn't didn't tell him i was lying and
then i just got a call from him like
a month later and he was like hey what
the [ __ ] are you talking about people
are seeing this
would you rather bang a bunch of models
but nobody knows
or not actually [ __ ] them and i never
would think you did easy pieces dude
i've already [ __ ] a bunch of models i
do it all the time
you guys never met them but they're out
there and they're [ __ ] victims of
mine that's what i call them
nobody enjoys sex with ari uh no i would
for sure [ __ ] models i don't care who
thinks anything it doesn't matter what
are you crazy
who brags about [ __ ] like that keep
taking that getting your dick
wet keep getting that butt what's the
worst possible way for someone to catch
you jerking off
outside their window uh is you're going
to jail
yeah yeah that is the embarrassment
the legal issue there is like they've
got you it's a it's a known crime it's a
named crime yeah a peeping tom
uh if they walk in and you trust like
your own dick yeah so that would be a
bad one
yeah and also i'm a finisher so even if
they catch me i'm like [ __ ] i'm not
getting
out of there i'm going faster but i'm
not getting out of there
last one they're gonna catch me i gotta
actually stop
doing that now because what if they do
catch me masturbating in front of a
window i'm realizing now i've been
i've been taking a chance would you bite
the head off a gerbil's head
for five thousand dollars that's
probably not enough for you right
no it depends no no no i wouldn't do
that for five thousand dollars
how much you got though well the other
the other option is that you can raise
this gerbil
yeah if you care for it you get a
connection with it i already know the
answer
100 000. oh i didn't know that was where
it was going
i thought it was like just kill it but i
thought you could avoid the random
50k or german you're a german
oh that's tough because also here's a
problem i
if i go the 100k way a month into it
you're gonna be like
[ __ ] i made a huge mistake and you're
not getting out of it yes
yeah you're thinking you wouldn't you'd
be like oh i don't because you don't
have the emotional connection yet
right once you have that emotional
connection it's going to be far harder
it's going to scar you i think i'm going
to go the hundred i'm saying like what's
going to happen is i can tell the
emotional scars are going to come
i'll take the 50 and then i'll invest in
a gerbil factory
learn to love it and [ __ ] offer that
up as a free show make all the money
yeah girl loop leopold loopholes
that was awesome all right thanks for
watching rshafir on answer the internet
go watch everyone else
on the app on the app you can play the
game you can watch all your favorite
comics
all answer the internet you need in one
app click here to download it
also leave a comment who you want to see
next
i was like no like just because he said
he was gonna do it because he's not
gonna do it